as ego driven individuals we love to
think that the universe is all about us
that we are at the center and everything
that happens happens because the
universe has some divine plan for us we
are compelled to believe that the
universe personally cares about us
otherwise what is the point how can we
care about the universe if it does not
care about us but just because we need
it to care does not mean that it does
the universe or a God as some might view
it is not a human nor does it function
like one it does not experience emotion
or empathy and it does not care about
the ways in which humans perceive and
experience what it is it functions
objectively and therefore fundamentally
things do not happen for a reason they
happen merely because of the arbitrary
alignments of time and space mere
coincidence but then why does it so
often seem that when things happen they
happen for a reason that every time
something happens to us it leads to some
purpose in our life that even when bad
things happen to us they can end up
leading us to good things certainly
there must be a reason why the cliche
everything happens for a reason is so
widely popular the real reason is
because of the resilience of human
nature and the power of our imaginations
things appear to happen for a reason not
because the universe or a god-like
figure is watching over us playing us
like a pre-written video game but
because as humans we have the power to
make things happen for a reason
when things happen to us we assimilate
them into our life and give them a
reason for being there we perceive the
alignments of time and space and
attached narratives and purpose to the
things that occur
we are the writers of our own story for
every moment we experience we have the
ability to write our own meaning for
every conflict we face we have the
ability to write our own resolution we
can learn adapt and create purpose out
of the randomness of life within the
universe and in my opinion that is even
more comforting than the idea that
things happen for some ulterior reason
[Music]
thank you for watching if we found
enjoyment and value in this video please
give it a thumbs up share your thoughts
in the comments below and if you are not
already be sure to subscribe to our
Channel
we are constantly coming out with new
videos to help you experience life with
clarity and Wonder